and Ashley says Matt after hearing your
comments about Rudolph I'm wondering if
you can offer a contrarian take on the
Grinch where the Grinch is the good guy
well it's not even a challenge I mean
are you kidding me to begin with they
tell you in the story right off the bat
that the Grinch's heart is two sizes too
small so he suffers from a disability
he's disabled he is a chronic heart
condition and he's been banished to live
alone in a cave on a mountain and yet
we're supposed to just accept that he's
the bad guy and nobody asks any
questions about the backstory how did he
end up there why are none of the who's
in Whoville concerned about this man's
health and well-being
the holier than now who's have
completely ostracized a disabled guy and
we're supposed to accept that his anger
is unfounded and I mean
You could argue this is a story about
marginalization if anything and it's
inconsistent too because we talked about
with Rudolph who's a deformed freak but
we're supposed to feel bad for him when
he's kicked out of society
and yet the Grinch doesn't get the same
consideration which doesn't make any
sense to me
meanwhile the Whos are frankly annoying
as hell they apparently sing all day and
night at the top of their lungs they got
no concern for anybody else obnoxious
and inconsiderate and I'm talking about
just the literary version here you know
the Grinch from the novel I'm not even
talking about the the the Grinch from
the live action film 20 years ago which
if that's canonical then
my point is even more Vindicated because
that really inadvertently reveals the
who's to be not only annoying but
judgmental and frivolous and fake
now does all of this justify the
Grinch's actions I'm not saying that it
does but I think if anything it's more
of a Michael Douglas and falling down
type of situation this is a man
or whatever he is push to the brink
and in the Grinch's case he actually has
a change of heart
revealing a depth of humility and love
and empathy never demonstrated
by any of the Whos
so this it's very much a hero's journey
I would say
I don't think that's contrarian I think
it's just I think how else would you
read the story
and that'll do it for this portion of
the shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]